the next Dune movie comes out in
November and new trailers and interviews
reveal new characters like fade ralpha
harkenen and Princess Ireland so who are
these new characters what's happening in
the trailer and how does it compare to
the book this video has no big spoilers
just some background info from the book
and from interviews to get us ready for
Dune part 2. so in the first dune movie
The Atreides took over the planet
arrakis in the deserts of arakis a giant
sand worms and a precious resource
called spice the Atreides were attacked
and defeated by the harkenings with the
help of The Emperor's soldiers so Paul
and Jessica Atreides escaped and joined
the fremen in the desert Paul had
visions of the future seeing himself as
a religious leader unleashing a terrible
holy war director Danny Villeneuve says
the first dune movie is contemplative
it's slow but that the next movie part
two is an action-packed epic war movie
The Trailer shows Paul and Cheney
fighting Harkin and Soldiers the trailer
says long live the fighters which is a
fremin Battle Cry this is a war for
control of Iraqis but amidst the
violence and sci-fi Shenanigans
Villeneuve centers the story on the
human relationship of Paul and Cheney in
the trailer Paul and Cheney kiss and say
they will stay together which is similar
to a line in the book Cheney's actor
Zendaya says that despite the intense
circumstances these are just two young
people trying to grow up and fall in
love she draws on relatable feelings of
teenage awkwardness and there are
awkward moments in the book Cheney makes
Paul blush and feel embarrassed when
they meet Paul and Cheney are from
different cultures they're literally
from different planets so they have
misunderstand endings they have a lot to
learn from each other in the trailer
Paul compares the sand dunes of arrakis
to the ocean waves of his Homeworld
kaladan this is based on a bit in the
book when Cheney asks about the Waters
of Paul's birth world in the trailer
Paul talks about swimming and diving in
water and Cheney can't imagine that
that's even possible because water is so
rare on arrakis that's based on a
different bit from the book where Paul
explains what drowning and boats are to
a woman in the Dune book we don't get to
see much of the beginning of Paul and
Cheney's relationship the new movie
explores their relationship more using
bits from the book to inspire new scenes
the trailer shows a soldier burning
corpses they look like dead a tradies
from the battle in the first movie
previously Paul had visions of burning
corpses and they were connected with his
vision of a holy war so Paul sees death
in in his future and in his past we see
a portrait of Paul's dead father lato
burning in the first movie we saw a
portrait of lato's Father The Old Duke
The Old Duke died when he faced a bull
in an arena and was killed like out
later faced the Harkins on Iraqis and
was killed now Paul is facing danger
will he be killed like his father and
grandfather before him in the trailer
Jessica says later didn't believe in
Revenge Plato spoke of Honor honesty and
morality will Paul live up to these
ideals in the book later says that if
they compromise their morals to survive
the honorable Atreides Banner could come
to mean many evil things the trailer
shows Jessica in a basket with some
fremin as they ride on a sand worm you
can see this guy steering the sand worm
with ropes because the foramen used sand
worms to travel and certain important
people ride worms in a palanquin this
special basket
we see Jessica with blue eyes which is
caused by spice you can see spice on her
nose like she's been snorting it we see
Jessica in fancy costumes and she has
markings on her face similar to this
Vision Paul had in the first movie
Villeneuve says that these markings are
tattoos linked with the prophecy of the
lisan al-ghaib the Messiah who will save
the foramen some fremant believe that
Jessica and Paul fit this prophecy that
they are the chosen ones these markings
are on Jessica's clothes as well as her
face she is physically cloaking herself
in this prophecy playing the role of
Messiah Jessica wants the fremant to
believe that she and Paul are the chosen
ones so that she can use the foramen to
help her and Paul and Paul doesn't like
this in the trailer Jessica says they
give hope to the fremen but Paul says
that's not hope because in the first
movie we learned that the fremin
prophecy is at least partly a lie the
Benny Jesuit planted this prophecy on
Iraqis as a tool to control the foramen
Paul doesn't want to use religion to
exploit the foramen though he does need
the fremens help to survive on arrakis
and there is some truth in the prophecy
because Paul does have real power to see
the future Jessica believes that Paul
may be the quizat's hadarak a superhuman
created by the Benny Jesuit breeding
program so it's complicated Paul and
Jessica are playing with powerful
dangerous forces of religion politics
visions and predictions and Paul knows
that this could lead to terrible
destruction we see a new character
played by Florence Pugh this is Princess
irelan Carino iralan is the daughter of
the emperor of the universe should Dom
Carino we haven't seen the emperor yet
but he'll be played by Christopher
Walken irelan is described in the book
as tall blonde and beautiful confident
and intelligent irelan has been trained
by the Bene Jesuit so she has powers of
perception control and combat in the
Dune book each chapter starts with a
quote from a book written by erilan
erilan writes about history and
philosophy giving us World building
details and thematic ideas for each
chapter irilan also writes about her own
life as the emperor's daughter irelan
had a difficult childhood she writes
that a royal family is not like other
families in her home political plots and
intrigues were constant and oppressive
and even her own father was a Potential
Threat to her irelan is a minor
character in The Dune book but the new
movie gives her a bigger role in the
trailer she says that the fall of house
Atreides is a dark secret and she
wonders if Paul might still be alive
because the hearkenons tried to kill the
Atreides secretly to make them die in
the dark despite the fact that the baron
promised the Bene Jesuit that he
wouldn't kill Paul and Jessica the
hearkenans think that Paul and Jessica
are dead they saw them fly into a storm
but it looks like irelan wants to find
the truth in the trailer someone
approaches a fremin then we see irilan
in a chainmail outfit is irilan on
arrakis hunting for Paul that would be a
big change from the book but as a
benejeret eroland would have the skills
to infiltrate spy and fight the Dune TV
adaptation on the Sci-Fi channel also
gave irilan an investigation plot line
it also gave her a similar white outfit
maybe they're drawing some inspiration
here this captured fremin might be the
character shishakly shishakly is a man
in the book but played by sirhela Jacob
in the movie these dead birds might have
been an attempt by shashakli to send a
message because fremin used birds and
bats to send messages we don't know
exactly what's happening here but it
looks like princess Ireland has a much
bigger role in this movie than she has
in the June book
another new character is fade ralpha
harkenen played by Austin Butler fade
rather is a nephew of the baron Vladimir
harkinen and is the brother of Beast
raban fade is The Baron's favorite
nephew because Beast raban is a dumb
brute but fade is smart scheming
ruthless in the book fade router is 17
years old a sullen teenager with dark
hair in ringlets though in the new movie
he's bald all the hearkenings are bold
and pale in the Villeneuve movies
because their Planet gide Prime is ultra
industrialized polluted and unnatural so
the hearkenings are sickly pale and bold
fade rather has a sensual effeminate
quality in the book he has full pouting
lips and wears tight black clothes so in
the 70s filmmaker jaredovsky wanted Mick
Jagger from the Rolling Stones to play
Fade in the 80s David Lynch movie he was
played by Sting so fade ralpha is like a
cross between a sexy rock star and a
psycho serial killer Villeneuve says
fade is charismatic narcissistic
strategic and cruel
in the trailer fade enters an arena and
the curving shapes of this opening look
like a vulva or a mouth how can an
architecture is about consuming
swallowing everything into the belly of
the whale because the hearkenings devour
resources people and worlds
fade fights a gladiator in the arena and
everything's shot in Stark black and
white Villeneuve said he loves the color
black and has long dreamed of a world
made out of one color with sensuality
and high design the man who fade is
fighting is Lieutenant lanville this guy
is a background character in the first
movie and a tradies soldier played by
Roger Yuan the movie's fight coordinator
so it looks like lanville was captured
in the battle in the first movie and has
now been enslaved by the harkenons
forced to fight for sport you can see
scars on landfills back because the
harkenons whip their slaves with a
particular Vine that leaves painful
scars Gurney has a scar on his face from
when he was a hearken enslave also in
the background of this shot you can see
creepy dancing figures with weirdly
shaped hats or heads so this fight scene
between fade and lanville will be
visually striking later we see fade
facing Paul Paul holds his knife to his
head which is the same a tradies salute
that Duncan used before his death then
Paul says may thy knife chip and shatter
which is what jamus said to Paul before
their fight so Paul learns from his
Atreides teachers and from his fremant
teachers and will use those deadly
lessons against fade it seems like Paul
and fade are destined to clash because
the Atreides and the hearkenings are
opposites the Atreides use self-control
to master their minds while the
hearkenings are beasts ruled by their
greed lust and rage we see fade roar
like an animal this is what Gaius talked
about in the first movie is Paul a human
or an animal when Paul fights fade
rather he confronts the Beast Within
himself so we'll see a lot more more of
the hearkenings in Dune part 2. this
promo shot shows the baron in a bath he
might still be recovering from lato's
Poison attack in the last movie
Villeneuve says that the baron is like a
hippopotamus because he's more
comfortable in liquid because of his
weight in this shot he's smoking spice
which is wonderfully indulgent the baron
is a sensualist who craves pleasure
through food and sex and every kind of
physical stimulation the books don't
mention him taking baths or smoking but
this is very fitting for his personality
another new character is Lady Margot
fenring played by Leia sudo Margot
watches fade rather fight in the arena
and the two have a closer encounter
later there's also this shot of what
might be Margot arriving on the harken
and Planet gidi Prime because the
surface of giedi is full of bitter oil
and pollution which is kind of how this
black dirt looks but who is Margot
Margot is a Bene Jesuit like irolan and
Jessica so she has powers of perception
combat and control she is described in
the books as golden head and willowy
Perfection of figure Margot is married
to count hasimir fenring who might be
played by Tim Blake Nelson it's not
confirmed yet but hasimir is a
politician and a friend of the emperor
shaddam in the book hasimir and Margot
worked for the emperor on arakis
smuggling spies and assassins they lived
in the arakane governor's mansion until
the Atreides moved in in the book when
the Atreides arrive Jessica finds a note
from Margot warning her about the
harkenings so it seems like Margot wants
to help the Atreides although her
husband hasimir works for the Emperor
who wants to destroy the Atreides and
the Bene Jesuit have their own plans
with Margot so the fan rings have
complicated relationships with the great
powers of this universe whose side are
they on Villeneuve says that Margot is a
secret agent and that she's full of
surprises Gurney Hallock appears in the
trailer remember Gurney is one of Paul's
teachers and is one of the greatest
warriors in this universe last time we
saw Gurney he was fighting against the
hearkenans in battle and in the book we
don't know for a while if Gurney
survives that battle but the trailer
shows he lives to fight again his hair
is longer now so it looks like some time
has passed Villeneuve says Gurney has
come back to avenge his friends the
trailer shows some fremin going through
a fancy door underground it might be the
entrance to a Siege of fremin settlement
it's unlocked with some kind of finger
scanner in the book Jessica opens a lock
that reads the shape of her hand so
maybe this is similar technology the
machine also looks similar to the pain
box from the first movie Dune often
repeats this imagery of facing pain
facing a test so that you can learn and
improve yourself so the centerpiece of
the trailer is Paul facing a deadly test
he tries to ride a sand worm in Fremont
culture riding a worm for the first time
is a coming-of-age ritual this is how a
boy becomes a man the phallic worm
suggests sexual maturity and there's
also religious connotations because the
sand worms are like gods to the foramen
they call them shy halud and maker the
way it works is the fremin plants a
device called a thumper the thumper
makes a rhythmic noise which vibrates
through the ground and attracts a sand
worm then the fremin uses these maker
hooks to climb up onto the worm when
they stick a hook under the sand worm's
scales the sand worm rolls and turns to
keep its Exposed Skin away from the
ground so by pulling the hooks a fremin
can steer the worm and travel where they
wish but getting on top of the giant
moving worm is very dangerous it's easy
to fall and get crushed so facing the
worm is like The Old Duke facing the
bull like later facing the baron Paul
facing the gomja bar and Hunter seeker
and Jamis this is a deadly test that
Paul can only survive through Mastery of
his body and mind in the trailer
stillguard tells Paul to keep his worm
ride simple nothing fancy just do it
safely stilgar says the same thing in
the book because sometimes young fremen
get too excited and proud and they show
off with tricks like dancing and doing
handstands Atop The Worm Paul might like
to show off in front of his crushed
Cheney but still go doesn't want Paul to
take a dumb risk and get killed in the
trailer Paul Falls and almost dies but
he rises again and rides the worm he is
now a man a full framen and the framen
are elated maybe Paul really is the
Messiah the trailer ends with a huge
crowd of fremin cheering for Paul it
feels triumphant but remember Paul's
Visions in the first movie of the
cheering crowds that bring terrible
destruction he sees a holy war spreading
across the universe like unquenchable
fire a war in my name in the book kinds
thinks that no more terrible disaster
could befall your people than for them
to fall into the hands of a hero
to go deeper into Dune check out these
videos on nebula Tale foundries video
about the genre of Dune argues that the
story finds the Fantastical not in Magic
but in humanity itself and Thomas flight
explains some techniques used in the
first dune movies sound design both
these videos are only available on
nebula an independent creator-owned
video site where we don't have to worry
about demonetization or the algorithm
nebula also has classes with people like
Tom Nicholas teaching how they make
videos and nebula is where Lindsay Ellis
exclusively posts her videos now
including an essay on the adaptation of
The Lord of the Rings there's a lot of
great content on nebula and using the
link below you can get 40 off an annual
plan you'll get exclusive content and
support independent creators including
alt shift X thanks for watching and
thanks to the patrons including scene
Jaron Caleb Mattingly Crystal baltinio
and Isaac B cheers
it's breathtaking your breathtaking